[MUSIC PLAYING]
"Imara," the word
means power in Swahili.
It is also the name of
an outreach effort that
has begun at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology's
Computer Science and Artificial
Intelligence Laboratory.
CSAIL is an
interdepartmental laboratory
that includes faculty from
electrical engineering
and computer science, mechanical
engineering, mathematics, brain
and cognitive science,
aeronautics and astronautics,
the Biological Engineering
division, and the Harvard MIT
division of Health
Sciences and Technology.
CSAIL is also the home of
the Worldwide Web Consortium.
Our goal is to find
innovative ways
to enable domestic and
international communities
through a combination of
education and technology,
resources to which these
communities might not otherwise
have access.
Technology by itself is only
a tool, a means to an end.
But as history has shown,
access to the proper tools
can vastly improve
the quality of life.
Imara looks for opportunities
to provide communities
with the tools of
computation and communication
and to enrich these
with education.
MIT and CSAIL provide the
technical expertise, logistics,
and educational
resources behind Imara.
Our corporate and
philanthropic partners
provide funding and
equipment to help
meet each community's needs.
Together with our partners,
we find innovative ways
to overcome the
myriad challenges
of remote and
underserved populations.
We believe in solving problems
that the community prioritizes,
not pushing Western
ideals and values.
To this end, we work
closely with local experts
in each community to understand
their needs and values.
The underlying
philosophy of Imara
is to enable, not to just hand
out computers to the poor,
but to teach them
how to use technology
to improve their lives
and then in turn give
the gift of knowledge to
other neighboring communities.
We help keep this
self-sufficient cycle in motion
through longitudinal
outcome studies
and learn from our
successes and our failures
so we can continuously
improve our efforts.
Since Imara is a
volunteer organization,
we are in constant need of
computing and network equipment
as well as funding for
administration and travel.
Your organization can
play a role in Imara
by contacting our
outreach coordinator
at the email address or phone
number shown on your screen.
Thank you.